[音楽]
僕が今まで読んだ人生の中で一番正直だった雑誌の話をしたいと思います
その名前は言う
もしかしたら知っている人もいるかと思うんですが
1971年に松岡正剛というサッパの人が耕作者を作りました
で1年間も発行されてないんじゃないかなあですば短い期間だけでた雑誌なんですけど
例えば宗教であったり
アートもう赤で水の全部そうですね全てを凌駕して術
と渡り歩きながら発信していくとんでもない雑誌なんですね
僕はものすごいこれが好きで
と11月号の盗むという特集を読んでた時にですねあるページに目がとまりました
だいたいこの違うっていうのは白黒のページで構成されているんですがそのページは3
枚ティが全部淡いピンクだったんですね
題名は
えっとそれはあの本店とかコラムじゃなくて去ったひとつの広告ただの広告
それに目を奪われました題名はパーツ love
ここに書いてあることをちょっと読んでみたいと思います
半ズボンのポケットの中に入れた鋼鉄の部品を閉じ時手で触れることで少年を道の全体
を感知することができた
その部品がオートバイの部品であっても冷蔵庫の部品であっても少年に飛来する全体観
に変わりはない
パーツに対する嗜好をフェチシズムという精神病理学の手垢には見れてしまった感の
ある言葉で表すのは気が重い
せめて断片て経路指向あるいはパーツラブと行ったほうがさわやかっ
部分に感情移入しつつへ部分から全体会全体から部分へとめくるめくスピードで往復
できるような感覚
フォログラフィックな感覚と言ってもいい
もともと少年のパーツ love は1対1対応ではなくいったいぜんたい王だった
から
これを見た時に僕はすごい今までモヤモヤしてたところをうまく言ってくれたなって
思ったんですね
で僕はのモバイルハウス見てもらったと思うんですけどあれを作る時に何かこんな格好
で作業するんですね
でいつも corbis とかポケットの中に入れちゃう
でそのまま僕は散歩好きなんで歩いたりするんですけど
なんか好きな音楽を聴きながらそれこそ渋谷とかお散歩しててでパーツを触っていると
こうなんとも言えない夢想館みたいな
なぜか
すごい言葉で表しにくいんですよ
そのものを感じたんですね
すごくらジェン子で表しにくいアートでも音楽でも表しにくい
ではちょっと
大塚さんがしゃべったあとなんですが緊張しているからはからモバイルハウスあの作っ
た時に使ったのパーツ触りながら今話してるんですね
でこの少年が
例えば何かおばあちゃんがそのパーツ触りながら歩いている正面を見たとして
何お兄ちゃんは
バイクが好きだから触りながらバイクを想像してるのねって言ったとしてもそれは違う
んですね
少年からしたら
違うよ俺は未知の全体を感知してるんだよ
はっきり no と言います
言葉で地術できない価値そんな無形の価値
そういった話を今からしていきたいとおもいます
僕は福岡県の北九州市というところで生まれました
母親が長も来てるんですけどもの巣が本が好きだったんですね
風呂に入る時も本読むし彼女のベッドサイドには宮で身内とか乃南アサとかものすごい
品加工
うずたかく積まれててすごい好きなんだなぁってそういう家庭で育ちました
僕は知ってたんですね彼女の部屋の
このホンダの隅っこに隠しているものがあったんです
何か隠してるんだろうって思って
ちょっとこう食べよるとかここから本出して読んだりしてるんですね
そこで僕が見つけたのは
こういったすごいシュールな漫画
吉田戦車のいじめてくんとかクロマティ高校とか
僕は今まであの本読めば理解できるって思ってたのに初めて読んでも理解できない漫画
に出会いまして
初めての子シュールとの対面しかちょうどちょうどあの
ただが開けるといいですか木切ったことがあるんですよ
でもうものすごはアドベンチャー背徳感も伴って
それがすごい好きだってないですね
でまぁそこは10年くらい経った後に中学生くらいの時
相変わらず母親本読んでました
僕は何で金取る使わんとって聞いたんですしたら母親は
ラン4名と
この持っている感覚とかこのカッと開くこの感じ
それがいいんやろ
他が気づいたんですね
テクノロジーが進歩するっていうことと人間が持って豊かになるって事は必ずしも通り
じゃないしそれに普遍性はないっ
思いました
と同時に資本主義的にもっと速くもっと大きくもっと
多くの情報を手に入れるために作るプロジェクトには僕は興味は無いところ落ち着いた
んです
こういったように
本の隅っこに隠しっていうフィジカルリティとか
なんかの旅に出るときに3冊だけ本を選んでそれを持って出かける
言語ができがでできないようなかち
そこにすごく魅力を感じました
じゃあこれからの金取らどうあるべきか
そしてほか高校生の時にそう考えてたんですね
僕が行き着いたのは
真っ白な本
表表紙も中もしよう裏表紙も白
でもある台の上にをてばプロジェクションされて何万冊の本にもある
もちろん越小とかがあるので簡単なんですよ f 賞使ってもっと薄くしてもっと
メモリ増やして読めるようにするのは嫌い kindle ですね
じゃなくてあえて自分が何を徒にしているのかっていうのが俯瞰した状態で
テクノロジーを切り捨てる一歩止まったところでプロダクトに落とす
これは僕たち sanpo に共通する価値観なんですけど
パブリケーションを作り込むの逆アンファブっていう概念です
僕はモバイルハウスに住んでますこのさて多くにあった1号機ですね
あれを
ホームセンターから買ってきた木材を使い長い地下作りました
台風が来てるときに作ったのでもうすごい雨に濡れながら早く屋根作んないと僕も死ぬ
なと思って
もうすぐ頑張って作りましただからとっても愛着のある空間になったんですね
僕たちはあのモバイルハウスのことをモバイルハウスと言いません
1号機はチャーリーに合計合うラっています
チャーリーにすごい僕は魅力を感じているんですけどこんな空間線なんか
ときど t 友達を誘って中でお酒飲んだりします
すごい楽しいんん
でもと同時にものすごい違和感もずっとあった
画面をタップするだけで例えばスポティファイとかで散るドジャーズとかカテゴリ
タップしたらいい感じの音楽が割れるすがチープに感じたんですね
もっと違う
アナログレコードに高針を落とすような感覚だとか
擦り切れて10回しか聞けなくなるそういった一期一会のとんでもないパラメーター
すごい情報量のもので僕たちは生活を過ごしていきたいと思った
で今僕たちが作ってるプロダクト完全にハーブを使ってます
ぱいってプロワークとを作っています
これはと麻雀牌のような形のものの中に証明だとかそれに合わせて音楽の情報っていう
のが入ったプロジェクトですアルバムのようにじゃあペットがついてたり全く違う
マテリアルでできたりしています
もちろんデータ量は本当に小さいので usb でもアプリでも実装できるんですが
あえて形を持たせる
コレクションしたくなる感覚だとか
例えばこれだったらえみりって言う彼女がいました
9時から彼女が家ますその彼女ような空間のプレイリストを作っているんですね敗で
だとかコピーしたらノイズが入っちゃって劣化しちゃったり音するように作っている
実際に現実にあって手渡すことでしかその敗というのは交換できない
不便がジリジリ豊かになるそすごいせメディア位なんですよそこのラインを甘く見て
プロダクトに落とす
僕たちは生まれた時からインターネットがあります
検索したら答えに直刃取り付る
でも裏を返せば黒電話のダイヤルを講じ入ってます感じとかああいうのに思いをはせ
れる世代でもあるって言えるんです
は快晴では気づいています
スポッティファイじゃなくてアナログレコードの方がワクワクすることも
iphone で撮るんじゃなくてうするんですで撮って現像するまでのラグを
楽しめること
キレイに整頓された街じゃなくて自分の足で動いて
除いてそうしないと先が見えない赤羽に魅力があることも
今まで排除されてきたカオスとか雑味とか不便っていうそういったワードがこれから
重要になってくるんじゃないでしょうか
僕はこの考えに至る時にある出来事があって
この考えに確信が持てました
それは去年の夏です
その頃僕はバーチャルリアリティの会社をあの1号店モバイルハウスに住みながら
会と全国回りながら開発してたんですね
バーチャルリアリティに関わる者としてバーチャル等リアリティの違いわかんなきゃ
いけない
そこで長野の川のそばで二日間ほど滞在してた時がありました
facebook のタイムラインを見てみると
エンジニアお友達がちょっと unity cg デー
綺麗なおりあるなぁ水を作ったよ
僕を止めてるじゃないですか
長野の川のそばってパーンと開いて出たら
まあ水しぶきとか気温とか湿度とかとんでもないんですね
であるこれもう無理だなって
なんかもう
そこすぎンゴ化できないもうとんでもない量なパーツ love がある
ズームしてもズームズームアウトしてもズームインしてもどこまでも面白い
そんな経験をしました
例えばこれ
バーチャルリアリティの仕組みですね女の数センチ先に高画質な lcds 相を置き
ます赤や緑赤青のドットがありますね
そういったここになぜそのゴッドが表示されるかっていうと全部 cpu
パソコンでレンダリングされた物体に対してこの点が対応しているんですね
つまり逆に戻ることもできる
でも前日ってそんなに簡単じゃないんです
皆さんカオス理論としてますか
数学と物理の間にある理論なんですけど簡単に言うと
風が吹けば桶屋が儲かる理論みたいな
全然関係ないようなこと等が相互に関係し合って今のこの瞬間目に見えているものを
触れているものを僕たちが今ここにいるって言うことそれが
結果論として今この瞬間を作っているんですね
だから
そのカオス理論の中にバタフライエフェクトってあるんですけど
超が
あの羽ばたいたら竜巻が起きるのか問題であるんですよ
さっき大塚さんがものすごいここでエネルギーで動いたじゃないですか
それでさえも今の世界をちょっと変えているんですん
とんでもない
情報量のプロセスがあって今この瞬間がある
本来僕はテクノロジーはハサミやジョージのようなものだと思ってます
使いたい時に使えばいいしそれは絶対に目的にはならない
でもバーチャルリアリティ動く作っているときにやっぱり作るのが楽しくて
自分が何しているのか目的になることがすごいあったんですね
僕は今日言いたいのはあえてそこを
頭の上から見てみる自分が何しているのか何でこのテクノロジを作っているのか使って
いるのかそしてそれを切り捨てる勇気っていうのを持つ
そういった態度そのものっていうのがこれから大事になってくると思います
最後に
ソニーのウォークマン
初期の広告の1文を引用して終わりたいと思います
記号化されない無数の信号にくそう情報の命があるのかもしれない
先ほど
モバイルハウスに皆さん乗ってみたと思いますこれ以上誰も言わなくてもわかります
あれは写真でも伝わらないし言葉でも伝わらないしそれこそ相手か相方が入ったみたい
に画面越し見ても伝わらないんですね
現実にいるからこそを理解できる
そんなとんでもない
パーツラグ
たくさん発 love
皆う周りに転がっていますそこに自分のチューニングを合わせて
とっていく補足していくテクノロジーが飽和した今の状態では
そういった感覚がこれから必要になってくるんじゃないでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]